>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Silence ]
>> Eleanor Billington: Hi,
everyone, good morning.
>> Good morning.
>> Eleanor Billington: Good
morning, [laughs] good morning.
We are so happy that
you all are here.
Thank you for joining us.
Welcome to the 2016
National Book Festival
in the Poetry and Prose Pavilion.
This pavilion is sponsored by the
National Endowment for the Arts,
our nation's arts agency.
And the NEA we are currently
celebrating our 50th anniversary.
So we are celebrating years of
giving Americans the opportunity
to participate in the arts,
exercise their imaginations,
and develop their creative
capacities.
On behalf of everyone at the Arts
Endowment, thank you for joining us.
I'm Eleanor Billington.
I manage the Poetry Out Loud
Program at the Arts Endowment.
Poetry Out Loud is a national
youth arts program that seeks
to foster the next generation of
literary readers by capitalizing
on the latest trends in poetry,
recitation and performance.
Poetry Out Loud encourages
high school students to learn
about classic and contemporary
poetry
through memorization
and public recitation.
Started in 2005 as a partnership
between the National Endowment
for the Arts, the Poetry
Foundation, Chicago, and 53 state
and jurisdictional art agencies,
Poetry Out Loud has grown
to serve more than three million
students and 45,000 teachers
at 10,000 high schools nationwide.
We are really proud of its growth.
The program helps students
master public speaking skills,
and build self confidence.
But most importantly, it helps them
discover their own creative voice.
If poetry recitation sounds
a little bit dry to you,
I promise that in a few minutes,
you're going to see firsthand
the power of a poem spoken aloud.
A little bit about the way
the program is structured;
we use a pyramid structure,
so it's a lot like the
National Spelling Bee.
Poetry Out Loud starts
at the classroom level.
Winners in the classroom then
advance to a school competition,
then to a state and regional
competition, and ultimately,
they come to the national finals,
which is held in Washington,
DC each spring.
If you're an interested high
school student in the audience,
talk with your teachers
about Poetry Out Loud.
And if you're an interested high
school teacher in the audience,
please consider taking on
Poetry Out Loud this year.
It is not too late to get involved.
We have information on the side
of the room about the program,
so come talk to me or anyone at
that table after our session.
We also have a great website
dedicated to the program.
I know everybody has
smart phones now.
So if you go to poetryoutloud.org,
you can see the website includes
more than 900 eligible poems.
We have video recitations,
we have many of the students
on the stage featured
on that website.
We also have a comprehensive
teachers guide,
all free and available to you.
We have -- again that
information is over here.
So visit the table when we're done.
Last year we had more than
315,000 students participate
in Poetry Out Loud.
And today you're going to hear
from three of the state champions
who made it all the way
to the national finals.
Poetry Out Loud students are
eligible for prizes at the state
and national level of competition,
including a $20,000 prize
for the national champion.
Every year, Poetry Out Loud awards
more that $100,000 in prizes
and school stipends for the
purchase of poetry materials.
While a $20,000 prize
is nothing to scoff at,
we believe that the
real reward comes
when students connect their poems
to their own life experience.
A successful poem can
challenge us, teach us,
and invite us to view
our world anew.
In the words of poet Naomi Shihab
Nye, "I love the deep attribution
of poetry to pause, to look,
to listen, to pay attention
to variety, to learn something new."
This morning we have the opportunity
to slow down and really listen
to these students, to honor
their work with our attention,
and to open ourselves to learning
from them and the poems they embody.
So with that said, we're
going to get started.
Our first student is Nealy Seams.
Nealy is the 2016 Poetry Out Loud
state champion from West Virginia.
She was one of the top
nine national finalists
at this year's competition in DC.
She's a recent graduate of
Greenbrier East High School,
and is attending Marshall University
in Huntington, West Virginia,
where she studies theater.
Please join me in welcoming
Nealy to the podium.
[ Applause ]
>> Being in a competition
like Poetry Out Loud seems
like it would be a lonely
experience to those looking in.
But it's not.
Sure, you're up onstage by yourself,
but whenever you're backstage,
you're making friends with people
who think the same way you do,
and like the same things,
and are feeling the exact same thing
you are at the exact same time.
Especially at the national level,
you can broaden your
outlook on life.
It's a microcosm of the
diversity of America,
and it's at your fingertips.
Relating to the poems, and
the audience, and your peers
that you're meeting is
a beautiful experience,
and it widens your outlook on life.
And that's the biggest thing
that I've taken away
from Poetry Out Loud.
I will be doing two poems.
My first one called "Degrees of Gray
in Philipsburg" by Richard Hugo.
[ Silence ]
"You might come here
Sunday on a whim.
Say your life broke down.
The last good kiss
you had was years ago.
You walk these streets laid
out by the insane past,
hotels that didn't last, bars
that did, the tortured try
of local drivers to
accelerate their lives.
Only churches are kept up.
The jail turned 70 this year.
The only prisoner is always
in, not knowing what he's done.
The principle supporting
business now is rage,
hatred of the various grays the
mountain sends, hatred of the mill,
the Silver Bill repeal,
the best liked girls
who leave each year for Butte.
One good restaurant and bars
can't wipe the boredom out.
The 1907 boom, eight going
silver mines, a dance floor built
on springs, all memory
resolves itself in gaze,
in panoramic green you know the
cattle eat, or two stacks high
above the town, two dead kilns, the
huge mill in collapse for 50 years
that won't fall finally down.
[ Silence ]
Isn't this your life, that ancient
kiss still burning out your eyes?
Isn't this defeat so accurate,
the church bell simply seems a pure
announcement, ring and no one comes?
Don't empty houses ring?
Are magnesium and scorn
sufficient to support a town,
not just Philipsburg, but towns
of towering blondes, good jazz
and booze the world
will never let you have
until the town you
came from dies inside?
[ Silence ]
Say no to yourself.
The old man, 20 when the
jail was built, still laughs,
although his lips collapse.
'Someday soon,' he says, 'I'll
go to sleep and not wake up.'
You tell him, 'No; you're
talking to yourself.'
The car that brought
you here still runs.
And the money you buy lunch with, no
matter where it's mined, is silver.
And the girl who serves
your food is slender
and her red hair lights the wall'."
[ Silence ]
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
And my second poem is called
"Passing" by Toi Derricotte.
"A professor invites me
to his 'Black Lit' class;
they're reading Larson's 'Passing'.
One of the black students says,
'Sometimes light-skinned blacks
think they can fool other blacks,
but I can always tell,'
looking right through me.
After I tell them I am black,
I ask the class, 'Was I passing
when I was just sitting
here before I told you?'
A white woman shakes
her head desperately,
as if I had deliberately
deceived her.
She keeps examining my
face, then turning away
as if she hopes I'll disappear.
Why presume passing is
based on what I leave out,
and not what she fills in?
In one scene in the book, in
a restaurant, she's 'passing'.
Though no one checked her at
the door, 'Hey, are you black?'
My father, who looked
white, told me this story.
Every year when he'd go to
get his driver's license,
the man at the window filling out
the form would ask, 'White or black,
pencil poised, without looking up.
My father wouldn't pass, but he
might use silence to trap a devil.
When he didn't speak, the man
would look up at my father's face.
'What did he write,'
my father quizzed me."
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Eleanor Billington:
Thank you, Nealy.
That was beautiful.
That's just like the best way
to start a Saturday morning.
I mean, woo, good weekend.
Next up is 2016 Poetry Out
Loud Georgia State champion,
Marta Palombo.
Marta was the first runner-up
at nationals last April.
She finished in second
place overall.
She's a recent graduate of Cambridge
High School in Milton, Georgia,
and just began her freshman year
at the Belmont University studying
commercial music performance,
with an emphasis in songwriting.
Welcome, Marta.
[ Applause ]
>> I memorized my poem, but I
did not memorize my statement,
so [laughs] hello, everyone.
It's such an honor to be here
representing Georgia one more time,
you know, at the Georgia Poetry Out
Loud at the National Book Festival,
and to get to recite
alongside my fellow competitors
from earlier this year.
So winning second place at the 2016
competition was such a wonderful,
indescribable experience.
I remember being amazing at how
nice and welcoming everyone was.
And, you know, we were all
supportive of each other.
And I remember telling jokes
and dancing around backstage
because we were so nervous;
[laughter] so as we were waiting
for our names to be called.
And most of all, I remember, you
know, walking out onstage time
after time, just hoping that
reciting my poems as best
as I could would be enough.
And apparently, it was.
So it was amazing, but however
magical it was to be onstage,
I think one of the most memorable
parts was the after-party,
not because it meant that
the competition was over,
but on the contrary, it gave us
a new place to begin, you know?
It was wonderful.
I sang a snippet of
a song that I ended
up releasing just a
month ago on my first EP.
I heard original poetry that
left me absolutely awestruck just
at the capacity of feeling what
I was witnessing in that room.
You know, I heard monologues,
and poetry,
and singing, and more poetry.
And at one point, there was
some beat-boxing going on.
I'm not entirely sure; am I right;
and, of course, more poetry.
But it wasn't just a celebration
of what had come to pass,
it was a celebration of everything
that we had learned from each other.
It was a final moment to let our
walls down and share our passion,
creativity, and experience
this time not for competition,
but for no other reason than that we
wanted to share what we had created
with people that we knew
would appreciate it,
and we knew would love us for it.
So the poems I'm reciting
today are the two poems
that got me into the final three.
"For The Young who Want To" by
Marge Piercy is especially relevant
in my life, seeing
as an artist myself,
I kind of encounter
this situation a lot.
And "Mingus at the
Showplace", on the other hand,
holds a special place in my heart.
It takes a while to understand,
analyze and fully appreciate,
but when you do, it's
really impossible to forget.
So without further adieu, I will
be performing, "For The Young
Who Want To" by Marge Piercy.
[ Silence ]
"Talent is what they say you have
after the novel is published
and favorably reviewed.
Beforehand what you have
is a tedious delusion,
a hobby, like knitting.
Work is what you have done
after the play is produced,
and the audience claps.
Before that friends keep asking
when you are planning
to go out and get a job.
Genius is what they know you had
after the third volume
of remarkable poems.
Earlier they accuse
you of withdrawing,
ask why you don't have
a baby, call you a bum.
The reason people want MFAs,
take workshops with fancy names
when all you can really learn is a
few techniques, typing instructions,
and somebody else's mannerisms, is
that every artist lacks a license
to hang on the wall,
like your optician,
your vet proving you may be a
clumsy sadist whose fillings fall
into the stew but you're
certified dentist.
[Laughter] The real writer
is one who really writes.
Talent is an invention like
phlogiston after the fact of fire.
Work is its own cure.
You have to like it
better than being loved."
[ Silence ]
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
This will be "Mingus at the
Showplace" by William Matthews.
[ Silence ]
"I was miserable, of course, for I
was 17, and so I swung into action
and wrote a poem, and
it was miserable,
for that was how I
thought poetry worked,
you digested experience
and shat literature.
It was 1960 at The Showplace, long
since defunct, on West 4th Street,
and I sat at the bar, casting beer
money from a thin reel of ones,
the kid in the city,
big ears like a puppy.
And I knew Mingus was a genius.
I knew two other things, but
they were wrong, as it happened.
So I made him look at the poem.
'There's a lot of that
going around,' he said.
And Sweet Baby Jesus he was right.
He laughed amiably.
He didn't look as if he thought
bad poems were dangerous,
the way some poets do.
If they were baseball executives,
they'd plot to destroy
sandlots everywhere
so that the game can
be saved from children.
Of course later that night he
fired his pianist in mid-number
and flurried him from the stand.
'We've suffered a diminuendo
in personnel,
he explained, and
the band played on."
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Eleanor Billington:
Thank you, Marta.
That was wonderful.
Finally, we welcome 2016
Virginia State Champion,
who is also our Poetry
Out Loud national champion
for this year, Ahkei Togun.
Ahkei is a recent graduate of
the Governor School for the Arts
in Norfolk, Virginia, and he
just began, or is about to begin,
his freshman year at the American
Musical and Dramatic Academy
in New York City, where he
will be studying acting.
Since becoming the Poetry Out
Loud champion, Ahkei participated
in the Poet's House Brooklyn Bridge
Poetry Walk in New York City,
and that the Governor of
Virginia over the summer.
He will also be presenting at the
International Storytelling Festival
in Jonesburg, Tennessee next month.
Welcome Ahkei.
[ Applause ]
>> Good morning.
>> It's always a pleasure to
be onstage representing Poetry
Out Loud, whether it's a state
champion, national champion,
or just starting off as nothing.
When I first started Poetry Out
Loud, I was just a student trying
to get an A in my English class.
[Laughter] But reading the poems
along the way sparked something
inside of me.
I began to fall in love
with the thought of poetry,
and how I connected with some
of the poems that I ran across.
Excitement grew for the next time
I would be able to get onstage
and display this passion.
Three years of my high school career
consisted of me learning the ins
and outs of this thing
called "Poetry Out Loud".
Winning it all seemed like a dream.
Thinking of it was like
watching the quarterback
of the winning Super Bowl team
hold up the trophy and say,
"I'm going to Disneyland."
[Laughter] But when I
got the chance to hold
that trophy, I became speechless.
The moment was so bittersweet.
Because it wasn't just about
the title, it was about getting
on the stage and doing what I loved.
It was sharing life-changing
experiences with the poetic family
that I could never forget.
These people made it so easy to
enjoy the moments offstage in order
to be ready for the moment onstage.
These poets are a group of champions
waiting to change the world.
I'm so grateful
for the opportunities
this competition has laid
out for us as artists.
I am Ahkei, but we
are Poetry Out Loud.
Today I will be reciting
two poems for you.
The first one is called
"Always Something More
Beautiful," by Stephen Dunn.
And this poem it really resonates
with like the cores of how Poetry
Out Loud goes, the race of
what Poetry Out Loud really is,
and you'll really understand
as I begin to recite.
[ Silence ]
"This time I came to the starting
place with my best running shoes,
and pure speed held back for
the finish, came with only love
of the clock and the
underfooting and the other runners.
Each of us would be
testing excellence
and endurance in the other runners.
Though in the past I'd often veer
off to follow some feral distraction
down a side path, allowing myself to
pursue something odd or beautiful,
becoming acquainted with some of the
ways not to blame myself for failing
to succeed, I had come to believe
what's beautiful had more to do
with daring to take yourself
seriously, to stay the course,
whatever the course might be.
The guy in the front seemed
ready to fade, his long,
graceful stride shortening
as I came up along his side.
I was sure now I'd at
least exceed my best time.
But the guy with the famous final
kick already had already begun
his move.
"Beautiful," I heard a spectator
say, as if something inevitable,
again, coming from nowhere
was again on its way.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
This next one is actually one
of my favorite poems to do.
I started my Poetry Out
Loud career with this poem.
It's called "Football"
by Louis Jenkins.
[ Silence ]
"I take the snap from the center,
fake to the right, fade back.
I've got protection.
I've got a receiver open downfield.
What the hell is this?
This isn't a football, it's a
shoe, a man's brown leather oxford,
a cousin to a football maybe,
the same skin, but not the same,
a thing made for the
earth, not the air.
See, I realize that this is a
world where anything is possible
and I understand, also,
that one often has
to make do with what one has.
I have eaten pancakes, for instance,
with that clear corn syrup on them
because there was no maple syrup;
and they weren't very good.
Well, anyway, this is different.
My man downfield is waving his arms.
One has certain responsibilities,
one has to make choices.
This isn't right and I'm
not going to throw it."
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Eleanor Billington:
Thank you, Ahkei.
Thank you to all of
our students again.
I think they've earned another round
of applause, they're so amazing.
[Laughs]
[ Applause ]
So we have a little bit of time
this morning for questions.
So if you'd like to ask a
question, there are mics
on either side of the room.
You can come up to the mic.
If you're asking a question,
please do come to the mic
because we're recording all this,
and we want to get your question
for our audience that
is not in the room.
So I have a couple, actually,
before we turn to the audience.
And we'll just go in order,
if you guys don't mind coming
to the podium to answer.
So my first question is for Nealy.
Nealy has been involved
in POL several years.
You've been a state champion more
than one time in West Virginia.
And so I just want to hear from
you, how did POL start for you?
What was your introduction to it?
We know from Ahkei he was in English
class trying to get a good grade.
[Laughter] But we want
to hear from you sort
of what your story is with POL.
How did you get involved?
[ Silence ]
>> Well, I started out with
POL pretty unenthusiastically.
I heard about it and I was like,
"Oh, maybe I want to do that."
So I went to my English teacher
and I expressed some interest.
And then the next thing I know,
the next day in class,
it was an assignment.
[Laughs] And so we
all picked out poems.
And I won for the classroom.
And then I didn't know when
the school competition was
until the day before.
So the day of, I went crying to my
teacher, and I said, "I really --
I don't want to do this."
And she made me.
[Laughs] And then I
won for the school.
And then I went to states and
I didn't make it that far.
But after being at states,
that's whenever it really
ignited an interest.
And I realized that there
was more on the Poetry
Out Loud anthology
than fire and ice.
[Laughter] And it just, it
sparked this love of literature
and it sparked in me a love of
writing, which has carried on.
So yes, that's how I got started.
[Laughs]
>> Eleanor Billington:
Thank you, Nealy.
We hear from a lot of students
that they love this program now.
But when their teacher first said,
"You need to recite a poem in front
of the classroom,"
it's a scary thing.
I remember doing it in high school.
It's terrifying.
You do it and you feel empowered.
It's awesome once it happens.
But it's hard at the beginning;
it takes a lot of courage.
So Marta, my next question
is for you.
You mentioned songwriting
and having an EP out.
Is there a way that working on
Poetry Out Loud and learning poems
by heart has influenced your
creative voices as you're, you know,
writing your own work
and that sort of thing?
How do the two relate to
one another, if they do?
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Well, they actually relate
a lot just because for me,
I recite poetry the way I would
sing a song, like mentally at least.
And it's funny because my literature
teacher never understands how I mark
my poems, because I write them
-- you know, I print them out
and then I mark through them like
I would mark a piece of music.
So I have like okay, fortissimo
here, and then crescendo to this,
and, you know, it's like I mark
everything like a piece of music.
So honestly, I think my chorus
teacher would be more able
to tell what I'm trying
to do with the poem
than my literature teacher would.
[Laughter] But so they really
do relate because, you know,
whether the poems rhyme or
not, like a song, it's --
I think it all comes from
the same creative space.
You know, it's telling a story.
It's expressing something
within yourself
which is really all
that music is as well.
And just because there's no actual
music to the poem doesn't mean
that you can't sing it in a way.
So that's how it relates to me.
[Laughs]
[ Applause ]
>> Eleanor Billington: And my last
question is specifically for Ahkei.
You're going to start school soon.
You're at New York -- you're
going to be in New York City,
and you're going to be
studying acting, correct?
How does poetry relate to that?
Will it -- are you still going
to continue to read poetry?
Do you know you had a -- it's
hard to know before you started,
but I'd like to hear a little bit
about what you expect
to do this fall; so yes.
[ Silence ]
>> Well, I had been acting
way before I was introduced
to the poetry world.
I had been acting since
I was like seven.
So coming into poetry was like --
at first it was like reading
a bunch of like boring poems.
It's like, "Oh, God,"
and everything's rhyming,
"The cat in the hat,"
and this and that.
[Laughter] But then it's like
finding those poems that you relate
to is just like finding a
monologue that you relate to,
or just like playing a
role that you relate to.
It's kind of embracing that
story, which is what you do
when you're acting, and just
releasing it, and telling it
to the audience, which, again,
is basically what you do
as an actor is that's all
we do is tell stories.
So it relates dynamically.
Like it relates drastically
as an actor and poetry.
And it actually makes it much more
easier to understand the literature,
and know how to, like
work my way through it.
So this fall, I do plan on
continuing with the poetry world.
I do plan on doing some
more things up there
with organizations
and things like that.
I'm also a spoken word
artist myself.
So poetry is still a big
part of my life as well
as continuing with acting.
[ Applause ]
>> Eleanor Billington: So I have
one question for all the students.
And then we'll open it up to see
if anybody here has
questions in the audience.
We've talked a lot about picking
poems and how important it is
to have a poem that speaks to you,
because otherwise there's
not something that resonates,
and it's harder to connect,
and especially know something
by heart and care about it.
So how did you guys
choose your poems?
What was the process like for you?
I know some kids go through every
single poem in the anthology.
We've spoken to some students
who have read 900 poems
or at least looked at
them, which is amazing.
Not these guys, maybe.
But yes, if you guys don't mind,
Nealy, we'll start with you
and we'll just maybe come up in a
little sort of little rolling roll.
You go first.
[ Silence ]
>> Well, you go on there
and there are so many poems
that it seems overwhelming.
And for the most part,
I -- whenever I began,
I just started picking
random letters on --
because it's alphabetized.
And so I'd pick a random
letter, and I would look
through the poems on that letter.
Then as I got more involved, I would
find works that I found on my own
that I enjoyed and related to.
And if it wasn't on the anthology,
I would go and find related works
that relate back to that poem.
How I picked my poems this
year specifically, I --
with "Degrees of Gray," I
come from West Virginia,
which is a coalmining state.
And even though it takes place
outside of West Virginia,
I know those towns that I talk
about in "Degrees of Gray".
And there's something
so personal about it.
And with "Passing", it was also very
personal where since I am biracial
and I can pass, and that's something
that has always bothered me,
but I've never been able
to put it into words.
So after reading "Passing",
it was someone understands me,
and now I can vocalize this.
And that's how I picked
mine this year.
[ Applause ]
>> Well, mine were mostly
by accident the first year.
There's an option on the website
that says, "Find random poem."
[Laughs] And so basically because
I didn't want to have to go
through the whole anthology, or like
go by letter and then be like, "Oh,
I didn't check that letter.
That's such a great poem,
why didn't I do that,"
I would just click
"random" and read it.
If it didn't inspire me by
like the first couple lines,
I'd be like, "No, next, next, next."
And so the first year, that's
really how I found those poems.
It's just I kind of waited to see
something that would inspire me.
And it's not that I stopped
doing that as I went on,
because I've done it all four years.
But by the time I got to the
year that took me to nationals,
"Mingus at the Showplace" had
been done by a girl in my school
who didn't advance, but
I just loved the poem.
It was just so interesting.
I didn't understand
it when she said it.
And so that really
bothered me because I wanted
to be able to understand it.
So I went and I looked
it up, and I read it,
and I read it, and I read it.
And so that's how I decided,
"I'm going to do this."
"For the Young Who Want To"
was completely by accident,
just through the anthology
and I read it,
and I was like, "This is awesome.
I need to do this."
You know, I just -- I
understood it so well.
And my first poem that I
didn't recite was "Echo".
And so that was -- I had come
across it a previous year,
and then I heard someone recite it.
And I love Christina
Rossetti like as a poet.
So I just -- I really wanted to do
something by her, and to be able
to kind of get into that mindset.
So that's how I chose them,
mostly by accident, and
some on purpose, so.
[Laughs]
[ Applause ]
>> That's exactly how I feel
about picking the poems.
Like it is such a long process.
It's like I had to dedicate
myself like to a whole night
of just picking out poems.
It's literally like a
five-hour process for me.
Because it's literally reading
through poems in the anthology,
and it's like, "Oh, no, this
one is about a dog in a house.
I don't have a dog so I don't
want to talk about that one."
But mostly I do it very
methodically, though.
I always want to find like a
fun poem to do, because I feel
like you should have
fun with poetry,
and I feel like that's what
a lot of people forget.
They feel like -- again like
I said at first they felt
like it's just a bunch
of boring poems.
But a lot of those poems on
there are actually really fun.
And then again at the same
time, I like to find poems
that I really connect with.
So it'll be those poems where I'm
like, "Oh, my God, this is me.
This is me.
I should have written this."
So those are the ones where
I'd probably be like, "Okay;
I want to do this one," because
it's easier to do and recite poems
that you actually relate to,
but it is a long process
to pick a poem out.
But yes, that's my process, though.
>> Eleanor Billington: Thanks a lot.
[ Applause ]
We have a little bit of time left.
Does anyone in the
audience have questions?
If you do, just come up to
the mics on either side.
Do you have a question in the back?
Yes? Can you come to
the mic, do you mind?
I know it's a hassle.
It's just because we're recording.
Yes; you right there.
I'm sorry.
[Laughs] Thank you, guys.
We appreciate that.
[ Silence ]
>> Is this on?
>> Eleanor Billington: Go ahead.
>> So why do you only choose through
the anthology; because Nealy, right,
you said that you found something
that you liked, but you didn't --
you couldn't use it, and
then you had to like go
to the anthology and
see how it worked.
Like why did you only
choose from the anthology?
>> Eleanor Billington: Do you -- I
can answer that as well as Nealy.
Nealy had to choose
from the anthology.
The way this program works is
we have an anthology online
of about 900 plus poems.
And those are the poems that
the students can recite from.
So those are the poems that
we've negotiated rights for,
they're the ones that are
included in our anthology.
And so every summer, we update that.
So we're always looking for
suggestions from anyone.
Students can suggest poems,
teachers, the general public.
So during the summer, we go
through the whole anthology,
and we decide which
poems we're going to add,
and how to negotiate rights for
that, and that kind of thing.
So that's the way that it works.
So if you guys have ideas and
if you want to email the NEA,
me in particular, we
accept ideas all year long.
And then we look at the poem over
the summer -- I mean, excuse me,
we look at the anthology over the
summer to add, you know, new poems.
So yes Nealy, Ahkei, Marta, they
had to choose from that anthology.
Oftentimes, a student will
say, "I love this poem.
Why is it not in there?"
And they'll tell us
and we'll say, "Great,"
and we try to add it that summer.
So that's how it works.
Yes, yes, of course.
[Laughs] Anyone else?
Oh, right here.
>> Hi. How do you practice
your poems?
Do you have a coach?
Do you look in the mirror?
>> Eleanor Billington:
[Laughter] Yes;
do you recite to your
family, your pets?
Why don't we start
with Nealy, and yes.
[Laughs]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Oh, my goodness.
So well first of all,
you just read it a lot.
And if you have a poem that
you connect with, it's easier.
It sounds magical and
weird to explain,
but there's something
behind clicking with it.
You understand it.
Then you go through and
you mark out what it means.
You do research, you find out all
of the ins and outs of the poem.
And then you just recite
it over and over again.
I work with my theater teacher, and
I do it for my parents all the time.
I think they can recite all of my
poems as well, including my dog.
So he gets really rambunctious.
And sometimes it helps because it
helps me deal with distractions
that might happen in the audience.
So as he's like freaking out,
I -- it makes me focus more.
So it's just repetition and
understanding is how I do it.
>> Eleanor Billington:
Marta or Ahkei,
do you guys want to
speak to that too?
Yes.
>> Yes.
>> Eleanor Billington: Okay.
>> I -- it's repetition, like she
said, it really is repetition.
I mean, you sit there, you
print it out, and you just --
you kind of read it
the first couple times.
And then you're like, "Okay; I'm
going to recite the first stanza.
Crap, what was the word, you know?
And you're just kind of,
like -- it's just, you know,
you have to like get into it.
And so you kind of just go
stanza by stanza is what I do.
And then once I feel like
I have it memorized enough,
maybe not to recite it right off the
bat, but to remember it slowly piece
by piece, and even if I have
to pause and be like, "Okay;
and the next line rhymes with
this word, so it's this."
I write it down, because
it really helps me.
I heard a rumor one time
that before you play shows,
if you write down your lyrics,
you remember them better.
And so that's what I've
been doing for my shows.
And I decided, "Why not do
it with poetry as well?"
And it actually really works
because there's something
about your handwriting and
seeing the words come out slowly
as you're -- you know, not
that you're speaking them,
but you're just writing
them out yourself.
There's something that really
helps me remember in that.
So that's how I do that.
Yes.
[ Silence ]
>> Again, I lock myself in my room.
[Laughs] It's a lot of that
during the competition time.
It's like a season for me.
I lock myself in my room for
about, again, five hours.
And it's just -- yes, five hours.
And it's just going over the poem,
going over the poem,
going over the poem.
I take it line by line.
It's kind of also like doing a
research paper, I look up the words
that I don't know, and make
sure I know what they are.
And then it's like if I can say it
really fast, I know I know the poem.
And then I slow it down.
And then I say it like
really elaborate.
So it's like going through it
and just, again, repetition.
And I definitely agree with Nealy,
the poems that you actually connect
to are much easier to just like
recite because it's basically
like telling one of
your own stories.
But it's five hours of
locking myself in my room.
[Laughter]
[ Silence ]
>> Eleanor Billington:
Thanks, Ahkei.
[Laughs] All right;
we'll go to this side.
Go ahead with your question.
>> Why is your favorite
poem "Football"?
>> Eleanor Billington: Ahkei.
[Laughs] That is a good question.
>> My favorite poem is "Football"
specifically that was actually one
of the poems that I didn't pick out.
In my ninth grade year when
I started Poetry Out Loud,
my librarians were
like, "Oh, you're a guy,
so let's throw you a sports poem."
But really it has nothing
to do with football.
It was just that that was one
of the poems that I actually got
to have fun with which
started, for me,
to realize that there
was fun in poetry.
So the audience really loved
it every time I did it.
So it was just one of those poems
that like it took me a long way,
and it was just enjoyable to do.
>> Eleanor Billington: [Inaudible].
Over here, go ahead.
>> Hi. My name is Kennedy.
And my question is, "What was your
inspiration for all of your poems?"
>> Eleanor Billington:
That's a great question.
What was your inspiration for
reciting and how you chose them?
Nealy, do you want to start?
You always have to
start [inaudible].
>> I can start.
>> Eleanor Billington:
Marta, go for it.
[Laughter]
>> So for -- the easiest one to
say is "For the Young Who Want To",
because obviously, you know, as --
you know, when I tell people like,
"Oh, you know, I study
music," they're like,
"What are you majoring in?"
I'm like, "Music," you
know, like it's a study.
[Laughs] So, you know, I've
gotten that question a few times.
And so it's funny because I
read this poem, and it was like,
you know, "For the young who
want to be artists, you know,
you have to work at your art.
And there are going to be people
that are like, 'Are you going
to get a job'," you
know, like, "Okay."
So my inspiration for
that was really kind
of just I really understood
what they were talking about.
And I was like, "I want to do this
because it really is good advice."
You know, talent is an
invention you have to work at it.
So I thought it was really
great advice for myself.
And I wanted to share it because I
knew that I'd be in a room full of,
you know, writers,
artists, poets, everything.
So I just felt like I
really needed it to be said.
"Mingus at the Showplace" --
there's just this element of,
like childish wonder to it that
I really loved because, you know,
this -- and it's -- there's
also so much uncertainty.
You know, this kid
like worships Mingus.
And, you know, Mingus
is just this kind
of this larger than life person.
And then, you know, at
the end, he's, you know,
dismissing his staff and, you
know, just a normal human being.
And you get to kind of see
a little aspect of that.
And I really loved
that about, you know,
this kid who thinks he's
got it all figured out.
He's like, "Oh, I'm 17 and I'm
so miserable," and, you know,
"I suck at writing poetry,"
you know, just stuff like that.
So there's really so many
little aspects to it.
And I loved that the poem itself
never really completed any
of those aspects, it just
left you figure to them
as the kid himself
is figuring them out.
So I really loved that about it.
And I, again, felt like
it needed to be said.
So really the inspiration for
reciting is more just when you feel
that something needs to be
shared with other people,
and when you love it because you
feel like you can just say it.
And I think that's really
what most of the inspiration
for reciting comes from, so.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Well, like I said, where I came
from helped with "Degrees of Gray",
and who I am helped
inspire me for "Passing".
But what keeps me reciting, and
what keeps me interested is there's
personal growth that happens
every time you read a poem.
And then a little bit more
happens whenever you memorize it.
And then whenever you get to
share it with other people,
you learn about literature,
and you learn about yourself.
Sometimes I read a
poem, and I just have
to ask myself, "Why do I like this?"
And so I learn more about
myself with other people's work.
And it gives me new ways to relate
to myself and to other people.
And you find out about so many
different aspects of the world
and views every time
you read a new poem.
So that's why I keep reciting,
and keep reading poetry.
[ Silence ]
>> My inspiration goes
back to, of course,
the poems that we connect to.
It's one of those things -- and
I believe Nealy said it earlier,
she said it's like the
things that you want to say,
but you don't know how
to put it into words,
and it's all right there in a poem.
So it's like one of those things
where it's like you can't wait
to really express that
part of yourself.
You want to get that
story out of you.
One of my favorite poems that I
did during the competition was
"I'm A Fool To Love
You" by Cornelius Eady.
And it actually -- that's one of
the poems that set my mom in tears,
because it has a lot to do with
what my mother went through as far
as like falling in love, no,
that's not the right one.
And then this other guy
isn't so good as well.
And it's like basically that.
And it's just like those
moments where I can get onstage
and tell stories of
what actually happened
to me is what keeps me going,
and keeps me inspired by it.
[ Silence ]
>> Eleanor Billington:
Thank you all the --
ooh, hard to follow these students.
We have time for one more question.
Would you like to go ahead, sir?
>> Yes. My question is that is
there any tips for parents in terms
of trying to motivate
their sons and daughters,
especially my 14-year-old daughter,
who's more involved and engaged
with her iPhone than, you know,
reading the written poetry?
>> Eleanor Billington:
That is a great question.
I cannot speak to that.
I have a six-month-old baby,
and so she does exactly what
I tell her to right now.
[Laughter] But I'm wondering --
and I don't want to put anyone on
the spot here, but do you mind?
So this is Ahkei's mother, and
she might have some -- yes.
[ Applause ]
>> I will just say that I am so --
anytime I have the opportunities
to say it, I want to do that, I
am so very, very proud of my son
and what he has accomplished.
I love him so very much, and I'm
proud of you two as well, ladies.
We've had a tremendous time during
our experience in Poetry Out Loud.
Ahkei has been on the stage
since he was about seven,
and my biggest thing
in terms of him --
being able to do what it
is that he really loved was
to find the outlet
and to nurture it.
I have a son that plays football,
and I thought he was going
to say that's why he
picked "Football".
[Laughs] But I have a
son that plays football,
and he was very good as an athlete.
And I remember Ahkei being on the
football field, and his stepdad
and I sitting on the
sidelines like, "No.
No; you're suppose to tackle the guy
with the ball," and
he was like, "Hey."
So but it's those moments when
you realize that as parent,
it is your responsibility
to push kids
and to nurture the
gift that's in them.
And they don't have
to be like other kids.
And Ahkei said to me one time,
"I wanted to hide the fact
that I was a poet because
no one else was doing it,
and it didn't seem like
the right thing to do."
He felt like he had
to be an athlete.
And so then I knew it was my
job to pull that out of him.
And so he participated in programs
that nurtured the gift
and pushed him.
And I have always, and will
continue to be his number one fan.
So if I had to give any
advice, nurture the gift,
and always be on the sidelines
as their number one fan.
[ Applause ]
>> Eleanor Billington: That is a
great way to close the session.
We are so proud of these students.
We are so thankful and
proud for their supporters,
their family members, teachers,
they all have a chaperone
with them today.
So it's not just these
students who are doing this.
They have this -- you know, a great
community of support around them.
We hope that you all
will stop by our table,
which is right over
here to the left.
If you're interested in Poetry Out
Loud, we have free teachers' guides,
we have brochures,
information about the program.
You can sign up for our mailing list
to hear more about Poetry Out Loud.
Thank you all so much
for being here today.
Thank you, again, to our
students; they were just fantastic.
And we hope you enjoy
the rest of the festival.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.